-Okay, Nicole, it's your turn.
Pull the mic.
Let's see what you get, bud.
-Alright.
Alright.
-Let's go, Nicole!
-Come on, Nicole.
-Okay.
-Alright, this is
Wheel of Musical Impressions.
Here we go.
-♪ Wheel of Musical
Impressions ♪
♪ Wheel of Musical Impressions ♪
-Now, for this one,
you're gonna get an artist,
and you're gonna have to
sing a song
while doing an impression
of them, okay?
Let's see what you get.
-Okay.
-Heard you do impressions.
-Oh, gosh.
I don't know about this.
Oh, my --
-Whoa.
-"My Heart Will Go On"
by Celine Dion.
-Oh, man.
-But as Led Zeppelin.
A Led Zeppelin vibe.
Alright, good luck.
Best of luck.
-Appreciate that, Jimmy.
-Adam, Jam Band.
-You got this, you got this.
-Let's try it.
-We gonna rock out real good.
One, two, three.
[ Rock music plays ]
-Alright.
-Whoo.
-Help me out now.
Put your hands together.
Whoo.
-"My Heart Will Go On."
-♪ Every night in my dreams ♪
♪ I see you, I feel you ♪
♪ That is how I know you go on ♪
♪ Far across the distance
and spaces between us ♪
♪ You have come to show
you go on ♪
-Okay.
-♪ Near, far ♪
♪ Wherever you are ♪
-Whoo!
-♪ I believe that the goes on ♪
-Yeah.
-♪ Once more you open the door ♪
♪ You're here in my heart ♪
-Wow.
-♪ And my heart
will go on and on ♪
♪ My heart will
go o-o---o-o-o-o-o-n ♪
-I don't know.
I don't know.
-♪ My heart will go on ♪
-What in the what?
♪ My heart will
go o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o... ♪
-Whoo!
-♪ ...o-o-o-o-o-o-n ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Song ends ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
-I don't know
what just happened.
-Oh, my gosh.
You crushed it.
Oh, my gosh.
-Damn.
-I don't know what happened.
-That's unbelievable.
Okay.